european union finance and economy
ministers will strive this week to forge
a common approach on new rules to
preempt bank crises
the aim is to help a struggling credit
institution or investment firm recover
from any shock in an orderly manner
preserving its operations and minimizing
the possibility of taxpayer losses
at the next council in luxembourg the
irish presidency is determined to seal
agreement on rules that would require
banks and investment firms to draw up
recovery plans and lay out the measures
they would take to restore their
financial health if things turn sour
the ministers will debate the use and
size of a resolution fund for direct
solvency support the measures would
establish a bail-in order for investors
to help bail out an institution in
strife without relying on small savings
holders once sealed this common council
approach would form the starting point
for negotiations on bank recovery and
resolution with the european parliament
also topping the agenda will be the
council's expected approval of
recommendations on the economic and
fiscal policies of 23 eu member states
the recommendations made by the european
commission are part of the european
semester program they're aimed at
strengthening national budgets in a
coordinated way and thereby bolstering
the euro single currency